support move university and the
production of more video tutorials by
making the financial contribution or by
getting yourself one of these t-shirts
details under the support move section
of move University calm the link will be
in the description below thank you and
enjoy second matter law will be talking
about is the law of definite composition
or the law of definite proportions also
known as a law of constant composition
so who stated this law it was this
french guy named Joseph Proust that
pronunciation is bad I apologize what
does the law say though the law says
that different samples of a pure
chemical compound always contain the
same proportion of elements by mass so
what are some key words in this first of
all we're talking about a pure chemical
compound ok different samples of a pure
chemical compound always contain the
same proportion of elements by mass ok
so let's look at this as far as what
does it really mean by taking a look at
these examples so we think about water
h2o alright h2o is one part hydrogen by
mass and eight parts oxygen by mass how
do I get that well the atomic mass of
hydrogen is one and the atomic mass of
oxygen is 16 ok so here I've written
it's adam ratio right the ratio of the
number of atoms they have there are two
hydrogen atoms for everyone oxygen atom
ok so what does that mean as far as
their mass ratio goes well if we think
about how there are if there are two
hydrogen's we're going to multiply this
number one right this one for its atomic
mass by two so we're going to have a
mass ratio of 2 to 16 right so that just
simplifies down to 128 so that's the
idea there for water ok so as long as we
have pure water I nothing's in a sample
that were two other than water this will
always be true this will always be the
mass ratio 128 as far as hydrogen talks
if we have ammonia that'll be will have
three parts hydrogen by mass and 14
parts nitrogen by mass because the
atomic mass again of hydrogen is one and
have nitrogen is 14 so three hydrogen's
would be three times that one which
should be three here one nitrogen 14
that's our ratio there our mass ratio is
32 32 14 right for hydrogen to nitrogen
so that's going to always be true for
any pure sample of ammonia okay for
carbon dioxide will have three parts
carbon by mass per eight parts oxygen by
mass right for carbon dioxide so carbons
atomic mass is 12 and oxygen is atomic
mass is 16 so if we have one carbon two
oxygens right so one carbon 1 x 12 3 10
student 1 x 12 e 12 and then to oxygen
so 2 times 16 is 32 so we have a ratio
of 12 to 32 which of course if we just
divide each of these bife by four right
we'll get three here and ate here so
that's how we get that mass ratio so as
long as we have a pure sample of carbon
dioxide this this ratio here will always
be the case isn't this this mass ratio
will always exist that's going to be the
same for ammonia and for water so that's
basically what the law of definite
composition is the idea that we have
specific whole-number ratios right and
they're not they're not random ratios
and proportions as long as you have a
pure pure comp chemical compound the
ratios by mass for that compound will
always you the same that's the idea
behind this law hope that video was
helpful thanks for watching don't forget
to hit that video with a like if you
found it helpful or enjoyed it and be
sure to share with anyone else who you
think might find it helpful also if
you'd like to support the channel follow
move University on the different social
media links Twitter Facebook all that
stuff links in the description below
thanks and happy studying